When I started playing magic, mulligans seemed
like a largely uncomplicated subject. If your
hand is okay, you keep it. If it sucks, you
don’t. And for the most part, this analysis
reflected the actual state of the game. See,
for the first several years I played the game,
the official mulligan rule was the Paris
mulligan. If you don’t like your hand of seven,
you can draw a new hand of six. If you don’t
like that hand, you can draw a new hand of five,
and so on. In some competitive constructed
applications you might have planned out some
sort of mulligan policy for yourself, but the
general idea, especially in limited, was, uhh,
try not to mulligan, because it sucks, especially
with regard to mana screw. If your deck is 40%
lands, a seven card hand averages 2.8 lands.
If you mulligan after drawing too few lands,
the six card replacement hand will average
2.4 lands. God forbid you need to go to five,
because that hand will average two lands, and
will have a greater probability of having one
land hand than having three lands. Yikes! In
addition, if there’s a couple of pivotal cards
in your deck, every mulligan you take means a
turn later that you’ll see one of those cards,
meaning that your midgame potential is compromised
as well. However, this all changed in 2019.
The introduction of the London mulligan meant
that, since you get to see a full seven cards
with every mulligan, it's no longer the painful
choice it used to be. This is all the more true
in commander, where you get one for free. The
filtering value in being able to pitch a hand to
get that same number of cards again is legitimate,
and shouldn’t be underestimated. Taking that first
mulligan has no cost to you other than that it
requires taking your first mulligan, so if you
aren’t using that mulligan regularly, every few
games at least, you’re actively giving up on a
resource the game is handing you. In addition,
going down to six cards, or even to five cards,
isn’t that big of a cost for a lot of decks. It’s
a bit painful in limited because card effects and
power levels are less diverse, so drawing
a different set of lands, generic beaters,
and noncreature spells often won’t feel worth the
cost of losing one of them. However, in commander,
cards vary wildly. Despite my personal wishes for
the format, just about every deck runs a piece of
fast mana that will dramatically warp its early
turns if drawn, and there are a number of other
cards that will similarly have an outsized
impact if drawn in the opening hand—other
low cost ramp spells like Birds of Paradise, low
cost draw spells like Mystic Remora or Skullclamp,
and high impact creatures such as Professional
Facebreaker or Academy Manufactor. A six or even
five card hand with one of the deck’s best cards
will often be a lot better than your average seven
card. In addition, as I mentioned in my lands
video, the existence of a commander creature means
that decks will have a pre-selected card that’s
effectively in-hand at all times. This means that
when you mulligan, you know that whatever hand you
draw will have access to that creature—as long as
you like your commander, it’s literally impossible
for a hand to have access to no good cards.
So, mulligans are a great tool, and developing
your skill in something as superficially simple
as saying yes or no to a given hand will generate
you tons of advantage through additional free
filtering in the long term. In addition, not only
are there relevant decisions to be made during a
given game, but the influence of mulligans on your
decisionmaking process begins while you’re still
building your deck. We can see an indication of
this immediately with the number of lands people
choose to run in their decks—if everybody had to
keep their first hand every time, I suspect that
you’d see way more decks gravitating toward land
counts in the low 40s, the range that maximizes
the odds of a three land hand. But nah—if we
draw too few lands, the cost of grabbing a new
hand is relatively low due to previously mentioned
factors, and the odds of drawing a workable hand
within the first three drawn is pretty high. There
are also people who adhere to this principle much
more strongly than just absentmindedly
tossing 35 lands in all their decks.
There’s a particular person in my comments
section who advocates a land count of around
28 for most lower-curved decks, with the
logic being that an aggressive mulligan
policy can be employed to guarantee a high
probability of drawing into enough lands to
function. And let’s consider that plan for a
moment—a given hand in a deck with 28 lands
will have a 36% chance of having 0 or 1
lands, a 33% chance of having two lands,
and a 31% chance of having three or more lands. If
we’re willing to mulligan to 6, to see up to three
hands of cards, this gives us a 95% chance
of seeing a hand with at least two lands,
and a two thirds chance of seeing a hand with at
least three lands. These aren’t the worst odds,
especially when you consider that there might be
low cost draw, low cost tutors, low cost ramp,
landcycling, and other tools that can make a
two or even one land hand keepable. However,
this also calls back to the idea of mulligans as
a resource—getting to see more hands of cards has
filtering value, and constructing a deck in
the 28 land framework means that filtering
resource is basically spent exclusively looking
for the right land count. Now, this can be fine
if you really trust your nonland cards to be
valuable and trust your manabase to give you
the symbols you need, but you’re still giving up
a bit of ability to hunt for good nonland plays.
As a demonstration of this, we can think of a
hand that has two lands and some desirable nonland
cards. Decent hand, I’d happily keep it. But what
if we’d just made some changes to the deck, and
one of these lands got cut for a Ledger Shredder.
Suddenly, this hand has a very high risk of
missing at least one early land drop, and we might
need to mulligan for a different hand, a hand that
will likely have worse nonland plays. The point
here is that running fewer lands will lead to a
greater frequency of needing to reject hands with
desirable nonland plays. If we’re looking for a
hand with 2-4 lands, running a land count of 30
will give us that 66% of the time, whereas a land
count of 40 will give us that 76% of the time.
10% might sound like a small difference, but think
about it this way—almost a third of the hands that
the hypothetical 30 land deck needs to mulligan
due to land count are keepable by a 40 land deck,
and those hands might contain some really great
cards. This doesn’t mean that running more lands
is objectively correct—there definitely are decks
where having a lower chance to topdeck a land is
especially desirable—but it does demonstrate some
of the tradeoffs involved with running different
land counts, and the way that higher land counts,
and better manabases for that matter, can
increase the filtering value of the mulligan step.
Let’s say you decide to lean more in the direction
of filtering for nonland cards. What’s a good
thing to do with this filtering? Well, a lot of
decks will have a particular thing that they’re
looking to find—for example, a piece of ramp is a
frequent want for decks with a very specific curve
in mind, as is the case with the Goreclaw deck I
mentioned in my lands video. In cases like this,
how many of a particular type of card
a deck should run often comes down to
whether the deck is okay with drawing multiple
copies. In my lands video I showed a formula
for finding the probability of drawing
a card of a type, and while 20 cards of
a type does give a comfortable 80% chance
of drawing at least one in any given hand,
the flip side is that there’s also a more
than 40% chance of drawing two or more,
and there actually a lower chance to draw exactly
one copy than there is with a count of 15,
or even 10. Now, some decks won’t mind multiple
copies of whatever they’re looking for, but for
a deck looking for a diverse range of cards,
or a deck that is tight on space, running 10-12
copies and mulligan-ing aggressively for them
might be a better plan than running 15 or 20.
Another consideration that’s especially relevant
for higher powers is that decks can be built with
the intent to mulligan in different ways based on
the opposing decks and the turn-order. In certain
matchups it might be correct to mull aggressively
for a hand that will make a bunch of bold plays
early in a rush to gain dominance, whereas a
different deck pool and turn order might make a
grindier hand with quality draw and interaction
a much more appealing one to stick with.
At this point, I think I should mention—I’ve been
presenting mulligans as a filtering resource,
which might imply that each deck has a set
quantity of this resource that it should spend
all of. And this is the easiest way to think of
it, but it’s not exactly correct. Willingness
to mulligan will differ person-to-person and
deck-to-deck, and how tightly a given player
leverages their mulligans will generally depend
on three factors. One of these factors is how much
they care about the quantity of cards they start
the game with. I mentioned that constructed EDH
decks have more card variation than limited decks,
and this effect scales with power level. In cEDH,
a single power card like Dockside Extortionist or
Esper Sentinel might redeem an otherwise-painful
five card hand, and a high density of specific
stax pieces means that ditching a hate card
against three commanders that aren’t generally
that affected by it isn’t a large cost at all.
Another factor that will influence mulligan
willingness is a player’s risk tolerance,
and this actually works in both directions.
A player who wants to sit down at the table
and have a game where they’re guaranteed to do
something might be willing to keep a slow hand
rather than risking finding a worse one, and a
different player could use the same reasoning
to mulligan aggressively for a great hand because
they don’t trust their topdecks. On the flip side,
we can imagine daredevils of multiple stripes
boldly keeping or mulligan-ing and believing in
their deck to deliver them greatness. Ultimately,
this factor is a matter of personal preference
more than anything, and will mainly come
down to what different people find fun.
The final factor in determining mulligan
willingness is how confident a player feels in
their mulligan-ing skill. Less experienced players
and players who don’t know their deck as well will
often be inclined to keep a mediocre-but-workable
hand that a more experienced player would happily
toss out to hunt for a better one. This is a skill
you can work on, and the best way to do this is
to understand the ratios of different things in
your deck and how likely each is to get drawn,
either in an opening hand or in the first several
draws of the game. It’s useful to know that your
opening hands will contain an average of 2.5
lands and 2.2 cards above three mana, and that
they’ll have a 70% chance each to contain at least
one piece of ramp and draw. If this feels like a
nebulous process to put into practice, you can
also do lots of playtesting—draw opening hands,
play out the first several turns, rinse and
repeat. And actually, doing a combination of
these two—pre-play analysis and playtesting—is
the quickest way to build intuition as to how
various deckbuilding choices will turn into
practical early-game results. It’s easy to
see your library as a mystical block box, to
deify it as an entity that will either bless
you with wonderful cards or curse you with all the
wrong stuff. But it’s not that—the way the cards
in your library turn into hands is predictable
in a probabilistic sense, and getting a better
feel for that will improve your ability to play
your deck, both in the mulligan phase and beyond.